la rente dia l'os avocat et président de
république en sauveur 6 france
traduction les républicains établi hors
des états unis en france donc bonjour
andy aloses merci de répondre à nos
questions en direct sur rt france les
analystes tablaient sur une baisse du
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi il
espérait un million 285000 demande
comment expliquer cette erreur d'
analyse normal compte tenu de la
résurgence du coc vide qui était
imprévue là c'est comme la première
crise sanitaire quand ça s'est passé on
avait un niveau d chômage à base qui
était un record depuis de l'histoire
depuis 50 ans c'est un tendue avait
après la première vague après suite aux
mesures de monsieur trempe on a pu voir
la chute des ses niveaux de chômage plus
de créations d'emplois à niveaux records
si on reprend le mois d'avril il y avait
la création des 2,5 millions d'emplois
et les essais liste dont on sait surtout
les grands démocrates qui aura une
baisse et une perte 17,25 millions d
emplois ce moment donc c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui on a appris sur jean
ducloux ville il y aura une notice
mandela économies à court terme
quelqu'un que semaine folle et se
détendre mais se trouve à mettre en
place des nouvelles mesures
aujourd'hui il souhaite transformer
surtout les aident surtout on est à
l'emploi au stimuler les travailleurs
elle est sûrement d'aller sur le marché
du travail est allé chercher du boulot
parce que c'est ça la l'activité dans le
secteur économique
aujourd'hui est atteint par cette
stagnation vous parler évidemment de la
résurgence du coronavirus cette hausse
du chômage donc du coup problème
simplement périodiques comme vous le
dites liées à la crise sanitaire ou aux
inquiétudes structurelles quand même non
ces périodiques vous avez vu que là les
niveaux du chemin j'ai commencé à tomber
d un niveau record aussi au moins
d'avril et donc vous avez pendant deux
mois consécutifs vous avez une chute du
chômage ce moment là donc il faut il
faut
pour le coronavirus pour se battre
contre le chômage ça veut dire c'est sa
part convaincre un virus il faut laisser
le temps le virus
on a vu c'est cyclique il est revenu
pendant un certain nombre de semaines
il faut prendre des mesures qui monsieur
tron est en train de faire ce travail
avec son compte républicain parce que au
niveau des comptes démocrate
pour eux il faut simplement distribuer
des aides jusqu'à l'année prochaine sans
attendre sans rien faire pour stimuler
l'économie
donc on a des vraies différences des
politiques aux niveaux économique et
messieurs 30 à chaque occasion s'est
montré à la hauteur des six états
décident attentes
donald trump justement dans 101 jours
exactement il se présentera pour
l'élection présidentielle c'est le 3
novembre
demain ce sera dans son jour donc cette
annonce de deux demandes d'emploi 1
million 400 mille qui repart à la hausse
donc c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
donald trump une mauvaise nouvelle
cependant dans les sondages quelle est
sa marge de manoeuvre à il ya une marge
de manoeuvre comme il avait on mars et
avril et là je pense que on est même
dans une meilleure situation parce qu'il
s'est montré à la hauteur à l'auteur dé
sa la situation comme j'ai dit
auparavant je vais me répéter
suite à la première vague il a pu faire
et c'est lé chômage d'un niveau record
jamais dans l'histoire des états unis
les chemins a chuté à ce niveau donc il
va pouvoir les comment expliquer le fait
qu'ils soient en difficulté dans les
sondages mais ça c'était toujours la
question de quel sondage vous regardez
et aujourd'hui dont vous vous demandez à
un grand nombre d'américains ci va être
élu et a plus que 60% des américains qui
pensent qu'il va être la prochaine
présidente dont vous avez s'élance
ça dépend des questions des sondages
pour garder et les sondages étaient
erronées en 2016 sur 500 offre un
sondage qui a eu lieu en 2016 seulement
8 à 10% ont été dites et messieurs et
rend pas les gagner donc aujourd'hui on
est dans la même situation
ça va pas changer les choses ont évolué
il faut dire qui et comment
et ces sociétés font
les sondages on a eu déjà les marges
d'erreur et la plupart du monde 90 % des
instituts de sondage ont dit qu'ils me
surprend pas les airs dans 2016 alors
avec lignée avec la politique aimé se
trame au niveau de l'économie
l'écho vide qui revient vers par une
vague
ces batailles mais monsieur g et d'un
combattant et il va trouver des
solutions et il sera réélu en deux
points devant
je vous promets je serai là et bien vous
serez invités évidemment le 3 novembre
ans dit elle aux dernières questions par
rapport à donald trump et est ce qu'on a
entendu dernièrement sur le port du
masque et sa stratégie son changement de
ton sa volte-face
il a dit dernièrement qu'il ne fallait
pas porter le masque ensuite il a twitté
en disant qu'il fallait le porter il la
portait récemment c'est une attitude
électoralistes non je crois qu'il fait
sa position évolue en fonction de la
situation sanitaire au départ et si vous
reprenez les discours des grands
spécialistes
il est actuellement et qu'ils ont dit
j'ai amené un deuxième vague aujourd'hui
maintenant les spécialistes ont changé
d'avis ils ont dit qu'is à deuxième bas
vague il ya résurgence du coc vie donc
messieurs 30 a décidé d'adapter à sa
politique sanitaire et recommande des
portes du maze et le lavage des mains et
la distanciation social pour réduire les
risques de contamination entre individus
merci rendit à loos d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat et président de république en
sauveur 6 france 1